as a part of xbox's smart delivery
initiative halo infinite is available on
all modern day xbox consoles so of
course we thought it would be
interesting to compare the game on the
most powerful xbox system the series x
to the weakest system it's available on
a launch xbox one so a couple things to
note here the xbox one version outputs
the game at 1080p and 30 frames a second
while the xbox series x version is
running on quality mode and outputting
at 4k at 60 frames a second so obviously
the series x version is going to be a
sharper crisper image the real
differences are going to be in things
like texture quality and pop-in it's
also worth noting that because halo
infinite has a time of day cycle
sometimes the lighting and shadows don't
match up perfectly so keep that in mind
to my surprise when cut scenes are
playing the xbox one actually holds up
pretty well to the series x which i
think is both an achievement to the
scalability of the game but maybe also
speaks to how it's not fully taking
advantage of the xbox one hardware as
much as it could be of course the xbox
series x is a huge winner in the loading
times department if you enjoy this
comparison why not consider hitting the
like button and giving us a sub alright
enjoy the video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
looks like the main power cells are
fried
auto shut down
triggering survival mode
i'm going to try to overwrite
okay
if you can hear me in there
i hope you're ready
please don't die
please
don't
die
[Music]
yes
yes
yes
we're going home
oh we see their big guy you're not
status report
status report
what
there's something you need to see chief
we lost
lost everything
there's nothing left for us here
[Music]
i don't think what here is
[Music]
this is all i've got it's enough
[Music]
wait what what are you gonna do
improvise
close the door
ah the main batteries are shut down
we're stuck out here
[Music]
you have one bullet against an entire
army
what can you do on your own i told you
it's enough
so i see
they're powering stasis beam
we can't escape
you work on the batteries
i'll buy us some time
i don't believe it you made it
we can't go anywhere while that stasis
beam is active then we shut it down
stasis beam weapons all of it
how will you get back
i'll figure something out
is
he was looking for something
he
he killed everyone
i know
[Applause]
we should move
we're sitting ducks out here
got that hog you order chief
[Music]
awaiting orders
sure thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we got time right let's do that again
every inch of territory we take is a
step forward on your six
waiting here
so
how much longer can we possibly hold out
here
where are we going sir
we're with you chief
we're with you chief
you